pour ressentir l'ampleur de cette crise
humanitaire il suffit de se rendre dans
ce palais d'exposition transformés en
centres d'accueil pour réfugiés
ukrainien ici essentiellement des femmes
des enfants qui ont tous quitté qui ont
pris le strict minimum ici chaque
personne a une histoire déchirante a
raconté
les jeunes nous sommes partis à la hâte
avec presque rien
nous voulons juste protéger nos enfants
il avait promis qu'il ne tuerait pas de
s'y tenir je ne dirais pas d'enfants
mais finalement c'est ce qu'ils font
wilzig
dit mais
quand la guerre a éclaté j'ai cru que
nous pourrions vivre avec mais après
plusieurs jours ils ont commencé à
bombarder l'autre ville de toutes parts
alors nous avons dû nous résigner à
partir
les moldaves nous ont apporté plein de
choses utiles de la nourriture des
vêtements des couches et même une
poussette avec un peu de chance nous
irons en bulgarie
depuis le début de la guerre la moldavie
a ouvert en grand ses frontières et
accueilli plus de 200000 ukrainien pour
quelques jours à peine nous pour des
périodes plus longues une pression
migratoire sans précédent pour un petit
pays de deux millions six cent mille
habitants l'un des plus pauvres en
europe